[Music]
please don't get involved
yeah i'm good to go chin nice thanks
everybody for coming on on this early
monday morning it is a holiday it's june
18th
juneteenth
juneteenth end of slavery would you say
end of slavery that's right chin
um that's freaking right chin yep so
please dude a little respect
uh
the one of the good things of holidays
in california because i don't know if
every state honors it like california
does but it's an official holiday here
so kids have school off so no summer
camp for my kiddos so
they're gonna drive my girl crazy all
day so that's fun but then uh no traffic
that's the biggest thing no traffic
do you remember during the pandemic no
traffic it was beautiful i could get
anywhere in la in 18 minutes yeah
downtown west side
didn't matter
18 minutes
that's not like everyone's like oh i
like so big oh my god it's really not
just shiny people if you want to get
anywhere it's the traffic you know it's
not as bad listen i'm all over there's
way worse houston's [ __ ] terrible
atlanta
chicago
seattle you wanna talk about seattle
traffic in seattle come holler at your
boy dude it's a beast man
um but happy father's day too happy
belated father's day to all the papas
out there hopefully you had a good
father's day i uh i had a nice one
that's me wrestling with my kiddos there
they always want to wrestle they always
want to wrestle with with their dad
yeah busty love they don't stop either
man
nonstop
non-stop because their dad's big they
constantly harass me and beat me up
um but yeah i went to the malibu car
show
man my kids um
what this guy says some great ones today
i skipped it because i thought it'd be
slow oh my man you were wrong it was not
slow i'm with you i thought it might be
slow too but there were some fire ass
cars there you know there's some special
lamborghinis my kids love lamborghinis
drives me nuts
but that uh that's a 68 ferrari daytona
v12
i think it's probably a million plus
bucks like that is an ultimate fraud i
mean it's a ultimate ferrari they count
on the new daytona i mean i think
there's like 300 of them they're so
impossible to get but this old one uh
when i saw it drive by i was like oh dad
dad i told my kids like daddy's a
picture of that karma sounds like that
thing i'm like hey man you mean that
thing
and so i educated him on it and he did
not care
he was like dad's scar so old let's move
on and there's a
a pink porsche he's like let's move on
the porsche like god damn it dude
you know and there's always these dogs
there but
the lady that runs the
malibu cafe there's not the friendliest
lady i mean
listen if you're gonna put two labs out
front of the freaking cafe people are
gonna touch about you know she's just
not very friendly like she's so
disturbed the business is over there
it's weird because they've been trying
to shut down that uh cars and coffee
forever
i don't like it
because it you know it shuts down the
parking lot but so many people it has to
be good for business whenever i'm in
there it's booming dude booming
yeah father's day was good son made a
card for me um it was kind of disturbing
because the spelling was so bad
and it was very disturbing and then um
going around it was a great father's day
but this is how it went woke up uh both
my kids had a card for me boston was
just scribbled right because he's two so
that thing was kind of a nightmare and
then tigers he made it at school on my
cat iot did anybody did any teacher help
you with this he's like no like my name
was
spelled brayden
um
you say i love my dad more than i love
lamborghini's i'm not even trying to
tell you i spelled lamborghini um just
all it was i was like dude this is a hot
mess buddy what are we this is private
school education what are we doing here
and then my girl's like yo here's your
gift
i'm a double x she got me a xl shirt so
that didn't fit
so we are off to a tough start
tough start
tough start
uh saturday night was uh cristalia's
wedding in santa barbara
um
[Music]
little rips
could go for life rips cold brew not
gonna lie this is my pitch to uh
chris is uh me and him start a coffee
chain for sure we're both so nice
yeah that's all we thought and i think
we don't have to call it thick boy
coffee like we have life rip scot
whatever you want to do man it'd be so
dope but his wedding was so dope man it
was in santa barbara i drove down there
that's me and eric griffin there
uh because i went solo my girl didn't go
i went solo so i was the
you know the lonely wolf he uh eric came
with his uh wife so uh you had to take
pictures i had nobody take picture with
eric goes we should take a picture like
we're holding uh brian and theo but
they're not there and then we're gonna
photoshop their bodies in we wanted to
but then we just did that one don't be
mad that suit either daddy has some fire
suits i just never have a place to wear
because remember when i used to host
the pre and post shows for the oscars
the grammys the emmys all that [ __ ]
the worst thing about ian's probably i'm
not with him anymore one many reasons
but is uh i can't just they can't just
hire a stylist and throw me suits off
the shelf it doesn't work like that so
every suit i had had to be custom and
they have to cover the budget right so
it's custom but once it's custom you
just keep it so it costs them thousands
of dollars every show and had to pay
your boy right you gotta pay daddy for
his
first brain you know what i'm saying to
chime in on pop culture you gotta pay
daddy for the award shows that would
skim through i had no idea most people
that were performing but i did my best
probably another reason i got fired but
the thing is they just didn't renew my
contract but the thing is is uh all
those suits i you know
i probably have 10 suits from them
but i and they're fire shoots like you
won't see him anywhere custom made like
they're show fire have my son's names in
the inside also has like
one that suit in particular you open it
up has a bunch of famous mobster um
like uh their prison mug shots it's sick
really sick i've nowhere to wear them
though but so whenever i can i text
chris as i'm driving up dude i'm trying
to flex on you but my suit is fire my
man let me know what color you're
wearing because i don't want to upstage
everybody
but it was just a nice little wedding
i'll tell you what man after going to
dalia's wedding schultz's wedding these
boys my boys do it right it's not long
drawn out they say they're val and it's
out man and then the then the best man
speeches usually it's from a comic like
schultzy's with charlemagne his was fire
and then for dalia's it was um
oh why is it blank on his name his boy
and they go to his page uh linoche okay
yeah it was linocie uh linoche uh gave
the the best man well it was la noche
and then his uh youngest brother to it
was only brother uh gave the speeches
now the bridesmaid speech let's talk
about that
why could not stop laughing because it
dragged on forever there's through it it
just brought the wedding a screeching
halt but um because they went up first
and there's three of them and they
talked way too long but it was all
inside like jokes that no and all i
could think about is bridesmaids nailed
that nailed to a [ __ ] tea and
bridesmaid when she was like i still
wanna rock and sushi you know sushi
nights and she's like inside joke theirs
was all inside jokes everyone's like oh
my god
and then chris's brother goes on kills
it
and then linoche went on just set the
place on fire he crushed it man it was
so [ __ ] funny
food was good
the the ceremony like the the party
after afterwards ago the reception
was like this cool little room it felt
like you were in like a cotton candy
heaven it was like this little room that
cotton candy there was a small dance
floor a live band like a dope ass band
everybody's dancing stuff that's when
your boy left i snuck out but then to
the side he had a life rips little
coffee stain he's obsessed with coffee
bean that's where we differ i'm a
starbucks guy he's a coffee bean guy so
but there they are there the boys are
that's making my cold brew at 10 o'clock
at night because i have to drive back to
wake up early with the kiddos
it's a good time though proud of chris
we got kingston today man schedules all
messed up this week brian's in greece i
know you guys are still getting a fire
and kid we did we did an extra one last
week with jeff dye so that drops today
and then uh you know theo's doing his
thing
theo is doing his thing so you know
we're figuring out there were some uh
fights over the weekend though
my boy calvin keator and josh emmett
so that was the main event right and
then the co-main event was supposed to
be cowboy and joe lauzon and that didn't
end up happening and i don't
the one thing about dane is they've
tried it twice now you've never seen
that fight it's out joe lauzon's uh knee
locked up and he says it's happened from
time to time it's a knee that he's had
issues on he's like get a lock up but
then i just whatever do my thing and it
starts working is
for whatever reason it just would not
work he's like that was joking around my
corner man jumped on his back like i was
choking him out to get out of there but
just never worked
so you know all the years when my faves
i love joe lozan um that's a bummer
because that'd been a fun fight
especially that main card
but uh
you know with josh m and calvin keator i
think
if you watch that fight and we're like
blown away by it i think because
if you look at
because i watched it from the prelims to
the main right um
there were so many exciting fights like
first round finishes tkos kos like it
was on man so i think for a lot of
people
when you get that main event
and there's a lot of mismatches on the
car too so you can get a lot of cool
knockouts right so
when you get to that main event you're
talking about josh emmett and calvin
kate are two of the best best
featherweights on the frickin planet
neither of them are knocked out artists
and it's going to be you know that's a
real competition man high high level
martial arts so chances would get a
finish out there i didn't think you'd be
a finish
but
i had to go to the wedding right i had
to leave at
the ceremonies at five so i had to leave
at three took me like an hour and a half
to get there so i saw most of prelims
and i record it and then i watched the
main event at probably
one in the morning like a psychopath
probably one in the morning
but i saw online and obviously people
text me so i can never get away from
fights even if i don't watch them too
many people spoil it for me because two
of my friends are into it or they ask me
like oh what'd you think of that i knew
something's going on because i got a
text from my boy todd who's like man did
you have that going emmett's way i was
like oh thank you sir thank you i've
avoided it all this long thank you and
then i look up online and
i i went i love calvin keator he was on
the show last monday he's one of my
favorites he's a buddy of mine so i'm
very biased i don't know josh i'm sure
he's a fantastic guy watching a story
with his wife and the injuries he's
overcome and being inactive and then
fighting calvin keator i mean jesus
christ man and i'm sure he's a great guy
but i don't know him so i and i tell you
guys all the time i am biased i'm very
biased if i know somebody or i have a
connection with somebody it is what it
is i root for them unbiased i told
calvin he knows who i'm rooting for on
the show i'm very open about it it's no
knock on josh m i'm sure he's a great
[ __ ] guy phenomenal fighter but doing
it for a hot second
so i went into the fight even though i
know the the outcome i went in going oh
i'm gonna watch this and i bet i can
find a narrative where calvin won i'll
come on the show monday and argue it for
calvin and trying to change the
narrative for whatever that means i
don't think you have that much power but
that would be my
kind of take for monday's show i'll be
able to watch the all five rounds i'll
watch it twice so i'll watch it uh this
is how i usually operate i'll watch it
once on my own then the next morning
i'll watch it and then i'll read like
breakdowns of you know some of the best
out there and what they thought and then
i'll come up with my own kind of
take on it and i was like that's what
i'm gonna do
i'm gonna watch the fight with josh
emmitt calvin keator even though josh
won by split decision i bet i can find
spots and argue that calvin won because
i'm a calvin fan i'll change the
narrative watch the fight three times
there's no way calvin won well it's just
not uh
i mean that but at best you you know you
have him uh winning two rounds
you know but uh so you give for sure the
second round of calvin but outside that
it's tough it's tough his you know he's
obviously i do think he's the better uh
boxer and this was just a boxing match
unfortunately i think
josh could have done some more things as
far as wrestling and mixing it up to
definitely get a
way bigger uh convincing decision
even though it was split um
and i think calvin could use some kicks
you know the kicks could have mixed it
up for him i think that could have been
a big difference but he didn't want to
get taken down but calvin has great
takedown defense so you know it was a
straight up boxing match um i think the
difference was josh emmett just
you know the number one priority in
judging is damage damage done inflicted
damage and josh emma definitely did more
damages he just hits harder and when it
looks harder so you could see even if
cat would block it he kind of wins
you know i mean i don't want to say wins
because it's calvin keator but
it just had a bigger effect even if he
was at landing the combinations it was
more explosive more aggressive more
memorable for the judges so
um even that even that being said um i i
just i gave calvin maybe one round i
could see you give them two there's
argument for two but outside that i
don't see it i don't see and i hate
saying that i i was hoping to come in
here and argue for calvin and i just as
much as i love them i can't there's no
they got it right on this one uh 48-47
i'm i'm fine with that
the one judge 47-48 i'd love to hear how
they came to that conclusion i would
love it if you could interview the
judges after the fight like
so 47 48 get tell us why you gave calvin
those rounds and what round you gave
them and the reason why you did it just
so i think it would help the criticism
on the judges if we knew their way of
thinking because we have no clue right
we have no clue
we have no clue
um it's a great fight though you know it
did get the fight of the night
um you know calvin's in a tough spot
because
you know whenever he gets to the to that
the fight to get him to the next level
he's even though split decision he's
still a loss
so he's not going to go too far down the
queue you know he's ranked four now
um
so i i you know
he would probably get the loser of
uh ortega yair i'd assume it's gonna get
nice because if brian ortega wins um
do you get because brian the the
featherweight division is fantastic but
so if bryan ortega beats either
rodriguez
which is coming up soon
is it too soon to give brian taking
another title shot
right he lost to max and he lost to
volkonovsky
he had some moments especially in the
volkanovsky one with that guillotine you
know he had his moments but he lost
recently so i i don't know if jair wins
it's very clear who gets the next title
shot um i know
josh emmitt was saying title shot i
don't see that happening any faster he
hasn't been active enough
a calvin kater split decision win i even
though he beat the number four guy um
and he'll probably
i think they'll move uh
josh up to six or five
um i think the next move for josh emmett
because
you know he's been inactive and you got
to be active to get a tile shot right um
so he's he's been
pretty inactive gets a split decision
win over cater i just don't think it's
enough
to argue for a title shot even though
he's won
what five in a row now
yeah five in a row you know danny gay
shane burgos michael johnson has some
big wins he has some big wins but um
i just don't think the title shot is
next for him i think um he's gonna have
to go through a guy like arnold allen
um i do think arnold allen is the
boogeyman of this division so you have
to me you have two outliers in this
featherweight division that aren't
mainstream meaning
they're not
in the talks with title shot right now
but both of them have the talent to
definitely in the next year fight for
the title that'd be arnold allen who's
one what nine in a row
it's gonna be tough to beat that guy so
i'd love to see arnold allen step up and
fight uh josh emmett and people will say
well josh just beat the number four guy
arnold ranked whatever number six
no i i get that i get that but um
i think the hardcores know what what
what you're dealing with um with arnold
allen you know i think he's a guy who uh
you know he's coming off a big win over
dan hooker he absolutely annihilated dan
hooker so i would i would love to see
arnold allen uh emmet next and then if
emma were to beat him and then we have
because you got to let the ortega yair
fight figure out yell at the max
hollywood volkanovsky fight so if you're
emmett you've been inactive you gotta
stay active a big win over a guy like
arnold allen or even a big win over a
guy like bryce mitchell so the two
boogeymen to me of the division that
aren't in the talks right now of
fighting for a title would be arnold
allen and bryce mitchell they're gonna
be tough customers to beat very tough i
emmett versus bryce mitchell is
fantastic too and i know
i don't think emmett's this guy in uh
calvin kader sure as [ __ ] not this guy
but um
you know when it comes to rankings
because
arnold allen six and bryce mitchell's
nine you could say well if he wants to
get a title shot he needs to fight you
know two or three it doesn't work like
that it really doesn't i think for in
this division because it's kind of
tied up at the top there with max
fighting for the title ortega rodriguez
um again if yayer wins he's getting the
next title shot but
so you're gonna be waiting a hot second
hot second if you if
let's say dana came out in the press
conference which he didn't but if dana
came out was like josh emmett's next in
line okay frighten
december at best you know depend how
those other fights go and you've been
inactive you don't want that man you
really don't so i think emmett's gonna
get a guy like arnold allen or um bryce
mitchell
because you know bryce wants a top five
guy i think they move josh up to
five chan seung jung definitely
shouldn't be five i know you love him
chin
shouldn't be you're you're out of your
mind if you can wat and again i'm a
korean zombie fan
it is what it is he's at the twilight
square he says he wants one more fight
very cool
you're out of your goddamn mind if you
think korean zombie could be arnold
allen josh emmett
giga or bryce mitchell right now that
ain't happening in any facet
so i like the ravens like all right
that's just uh
that's just a respect thing we all
respect green zombie there's no way he's
the number five guy in the world there's
no way there's no way you think he beats
arnold allen joshua giger or bryce
mitchell and they're six seven eight
nine there's no way no can you tell me
he's gonna be
the guys ahead of him
tell me he's gonna be yair ortega
holloway we know he's not beating
[ __ ] uh
um vulkanovsky
he fought or take him saw that went yeah
you know so for him to be at five it's
like the guy's doing the rank it's like
oh yeah that's a respect thing which i
i'm all about it i'm with you man but
he ain't beating them i'm telling you
guys put star next to arnold allen and
uh bryce mitchell next year they're
gonna be real threats there i mean the
threats now i don't know it's number six
we're you know we're starting to talk
about him now but um
you know so for uh for emmett um
you know it's good to see a guy like him
that's overcome injuries and stuff like
that and he's you know he's been in the
home and show his wife like can't help
but love the guy and he's a he's an
exciting fighter too you know he's a
good wrestler but you know he he was a
uh
he was a golden gloves champ fellow
alumni golden gloves champ not a big
deal i won in colorado he won in
texas is that right jen well who are we
talking about now sorry uh emmett oh
where do you win his golden globe it
does matter it does matter
just there you know if you want in you
know
maine
all right
let me see this
um and was born in phoenix all right he
studied psychology and college with
intention of going to law enforcement
and there's he couldn't look more like a
cop he looks like robocop uh
bachelor degree menlo college you know
manlow big mark menlo college did a
phenomenal uh phenomenal uh football
player come out there uh it was division
three menlo or might be in at an n-a-i-a
uh his name was i think vincent jackson
or jackson something monster so [ __ ]
good at football played for the broncos
for a long time do that division three
is [ __ ] insane uh so i met wrestler
for 14 years began at el camino uh
fundamental high school well i thought
fundamental high school that one was
like secondary school you know what i'm
saying that was problem schools uh
continuing college years and then
arrested his first two seasons at junior
college level sacramento city college
before transfer and at menlo uh after
this uh collegiate career was already
joining ui favors ultimate fitness to
canoes desiring competing emma's also
accomplished uh jiu jitsu in world
championship blue belt okay
uh doesn't say where so i would assume
california
which is very impressive i think
california california new york have the
biggest kind of
uh i think california texas and new york
have the biggest um
golden gloves
competition
i mean colorado's no punk let's not
let's not throw shade on that okay
so he thought he was gonna get screwed
by the judges yeah and stuff
of course you did
yeah of course you did
you never again i would love uh
if the judges had to do short interviews
like just do it with someone who's safe
like not the mma media who are going to
light them up and like ask a million
questions so i'll just have like megan
o'leavy or um
uh who's the girl we love uh
laura senko like have laura saying go
sit down with him like let's go through
the judges how dope of a series would
that be
behind the judging with laura senko and
she sits down with him like how the hell
did you get here but she's not that
aggressive you know and she's easy on
the eyes so they're kind of like all
right here we go she's cool you know you
don't want my big gnarly ass in there
smell like musk and tobacco you feel me
and whiskey you don't want that you need
like a kind of a a nice
ambiance where they feel relaxed playing
some like cool music well you want a
drink and let's talk about the fight how
you judge that and then by then she's
like yeah your [ __ ] mind it'd be such
a lit show behind the judging
laura senko
that one's for free fight pass after
them start charging um
kevin holland had uh you know if you're
gonna pick a mvp of the night be what
it's tough not to say josh emmett even
though a split decision but really it
should have been a majority decision
it's a good fight especially being a guy
in calvin keator it's a big featheriness
cap um
but if you had to give a mvp outside the
main event be kevin holland kevin hall
looked fantastic
um
i i think what's next for kevin holland
you know after he kind of he fell on
hard times right and then he did his
thing went to aka
he's getting a lot better they're still
not putting him with a ton of wrestlers
tim means is you know
a widely vet uh for him to just
absolutely dominate tim means says a lot
about where kevin holland's at i think
for kevin i i think it's time for
another task i would like like a a
welterweight i'd like like a a wonder
boy would be a fun matchup i think
wonder wonder boy would be fun he called
out sean brady
now this is the reason why i like kevin
holland which we should get him on here
uh tell home girl um
kevin holland off sees a big personality
talks in the cage does his thing
when you lose obviously people you know
talk all that [ __ ] and blah blah but
he's obviously getting better i do think
it'd be a fun test but one of the
reasons i love kevin holland is you'll
hear guys call guys out
and they're trying to get the biggest
most famous guy that's the easiest fight
possible this dude called out sean brady
again i told you in the featherweight
division uh arnold allen and our boy
bryce mitchell are the boogeyman in the
welterweight division they're gonna be a
scarier guy right now than sean brady
philadelphia's finest and for kevin
holland who you know he is good at jiu
jitsu but the wrestling seems to be an
issue
shaun brady can grapple his ass off so
it's not like he's calling out the
perfect matchup like of vicente luce
who's going to strike with him like a
wonder boy thompson who's going to
strike with him like a horry mobslaw
who's a huge name no dude he called out
the philadelphia boogeyman and sean
brady and i was like oof i didn't i do
not like that fight for kevin holland
but you never know
he's getting better but yeah sean brady
he's gonna have something coming his way
too you know he is a [ __ ] monster out
of philadelphia these philadelphia boys
man they got something going on up there
man they get a lot of monsters coming
out of there and sean brady's probably
captain of that movement and he is a
problem the ufc is gonna have to you
know he
he's ranked nine
two of the guys above him
you know i assume that's who he wants to
fight he's been calling out everybody no
one's kind of taking the bait because
you know it's sean brady i think he's
another guy who
he's a problem for a lot of guys so you
look at jory mobs was not going to fight
him wonder boy might i think wonder boy
do what the ufc tells them to do so i
could see wonderboy taking that fight um
i would again i would love a haul in one
boy fight i think it would be fun uh
vicente lucas such a fun fight
for for uh
holland or sean brady if they don't make
that fight happen and i'll see muhammad
uh who just had on food truck one of my
favorite guests by the way he's
fantastic
you know say muhammad burns hans out of
course leonardo is fighting for taiwan
colin covington's kind of doing his
thing
so for sean brady it's like it's off to
the races it's just tough because
again that division camaro and leon
edwards title fight coming up and went
oh what they announced in august
the fights in august
and then you got
colby kind of they're trying to do kobe
hamzat on abc
you got gilbert burns at four
you got muhammad right there you have
vicente luke and then wonder boy
hawaii mazda who knows what's going to
happen there but dana did come out and
say
that the
the charges that colby come to suppress
and against juare doesn't affect their
fighting he was like
it's not going to hold it up they're
able to go which is interesting right
yeah i think because it's two ufc guys
if it was a regular civilian in jorge
and they were pressing charges i think
that makes it a little tougher for the
ufc to promote a fight
yeah i like neil magne
and uh our boy
holland
yeah
yeah you see is booming you look at this
they're [ __ ] stacked dude stacked
yeah i give holland uh the mvp there
they give him a bonus
performance tonight yeah holland isn't
the most ever getting up jesus christ
11. buckley adrian giannis adrian yanez
was interesting right because that tony
kelly he's the guy that said the uh
brazilian stuff bracelet i don't think
it was racist i think it was off color
but i don't think it was straight up
racism you know yeah um again that's why
i don't think the coroner should be
mic'd up
also going back to the corner in the
josh emmett fight his corn after two
rounds goes or going to the third goes
you're up two rounds
now i know a lot of people are
criticizing josh emmett's corner uh the
team alpha male's corner for saying that
this is why i don't give a flying [ __ ]
um because you don't know that fighter
like they know josh emmett might be a
guy who if he thinks he's losing he's
take bigger risk and kind of put himself
in a
compromised position
um i do think after two is 1-1
um it's weird recording go you're up
two-nothing but again i don't know the
the the fighter they might be saying
that because if he thinks he's doing
well then he's in a the right uh frame
of mind to take chances and try and get
a finish because if they go dude you're
down two
you're down two man you might freak the
[ __ ] out and who knows what happens so
they know the fighter best that's why i
never judge corner whatever they say uh
during the middle of a fist fight in a
cage um that's why they shouldn't be
miked up because can only get them in
trouble so here with josh i'm going
you're up to nothing oh that's
interesting but then my head i'm like
they know him better maybe he needs that
motivation like that's what motivates
him if he thinks he's dominating that
gets him to his
peak level you know that's why i never
question that stuff
but it is strange going oh you're up two
nothing i was like kelly you man those
are close rounds those first two are
close man yeah i definitely think you
lost one but again they know him better
than me so
maybe that's what he needs to get to
where he's trying to go
um yeah so adrian yattas who's a
straight up savage okay 5-0 right let's
see how much she is right now
i know it's at least five in a row
[Music]
oh schneider's this boy is doing work
so he got to start on the
dana white contender series august 2020.
he got a knock at tko in 39 seconds then
they're like right cool man uh you're
gonna fight in october in the real ufc
and head kick ko performance of the
night this dude has had
[Music]
every fight he's on ufc he's got a
performance of the night or fight of the
night
nutsos yep
now with tony kelly a he missed wait
and he got
uh finished in the first round
do they cut him let me see click on his
record how has it been going for him
oops
not too bad uh
two and two we'll see what the ufc and
then is five tonight all right
no they don't kill him yet
your boy adriana's getting it done we
got him on the show today too oh yeah a
little bantamweight badass
doing his thing so be interesting to
talk to him he's a monster yeah i mean
you have that many bonuses he's rich
he's rich he's so good he's so stupid
again
yep they put him on the
the to kick off kind of the main card on
purpose like obviously the kid brings it
i would do well in the bed after this
he's on pay-per-views
i hope so meaning like main card not
main event yet but main card yeah
abandon weight how exciting he is
um outside that a good card overall cody
stamen eddie weiland complete mismatch
is a good win for cody but that was a
toss-up
uh phil hall hawes yeah phil hall's in
toronto that was
yeah that they're on win he's just too
short for the division yeah he couldn't
reach him yeah it's a it's a nightmare
for him yeah uh he went hard at dc as
well i'm sure it's in your current
events let's take a little break kit for
me granting and chatting about the fight
world cuz man
i know you're like oh the nba playoffs
is over
there's no nfl there's no huge ufc this
weekend pay-per-view what am i gonna do
well sports is always going on man you
got mlb happening right now you got my
colorado avalanche in the stanley cup
freaking finals and they're up to
nothing the boys are gonna bring it home
so make money you can watch nhl stanley
cup championship games with the colorado
avalanche and you can make money they're
going to beat the lightning the tempe
lightning don't stand a chance they're
down 0-2 but watch the stanley cup
finals make some bank with my friends at
draftkings or if you're not a hockey guy
just watch mlb there's a million games
going on all right
gun on mlb make some cash dude whatever
you want to do it you got to do it with
my friends at draftkings all you got to
do download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code shop show
that's sch aub show all right and you
get a bet and then you're gonna win
a bunch of money all right you can win
uh a ton of money and free bets if you
start winning they have all sorts of
giveaways all sorts of bonuses your new
parlays do whatever you want man they
got it all one stop shop at draftkings
that's promo code shop show only a
draftking sports book minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
knows for details download the draftking
sportsbook app use promo code shop show
we gotcha draftkings
last ad read kids when we get back to
the show i promise
listen it's a thick boy summer it is
hair thick boy thick girl summer and
maybe your goal is to get shredded maybe
it's to get in the best shape of your
life whatever it is
you need some help man you need some
real professional smart expert help man
and that's where fit bod it's an app
fitbot is an app all right it's a smart
workout app that creates custom dynamic
programming based on your goals
experience and equipment that you have
they have this special algorithm it uses
data and analytics to build your best
next workout it maximizes your results
just for you the workouts ain't for
everybody it's not you know peanut
butter jelly not for everybody consumed
no it's built just for you to get in the
best shape of your life it's a thick boy
summer that doesn't mean get out of
shape somewhere that means get in great
shape so you look cool in your board
shorts you look cool at the barbecue
with your shirt off whatever it is
you're looking cool on the gram let
fitbot help you out man the app is super
easy to use all right there's hd video
tutorials that make learning new
exercises super easy all right it can
integrate with your apple watch all
right
apps like uh it works with apps like
apple health fitbit strava all right
that's one i use for my biking uh for
less than the cost of one session with a
personal trainer you get a full year of
personalized workouts with fitbot again
it's just for you these workouts are
designed custom made for use you're
trying to doing that no they have an
idea what they're gonna do for the day
then all their clients get it not with
fitbod it's just for you to get in
phenomenal shape the best shape of your
life it's super easy no more excuses
download the app right crush your summer
fitness goals with personalized workouts
from fitbod that improve as you do
that's right and it's never the same
it's always improving that's the way to
get in shape man get 25 off your
subscription or try out the app for free
when you sign up now at fitbot.me
slash shob s-e-h-a-b that's 25 percent
off your subscription or try it for free
at fitbo dot me slash shob fit pod
mr adrian giannis what's happening
brother
oh man loving living life man that's
just been the motto of like these last
last couple months man last i actually
like seven
uh of my life you know so
uh yeah best way to explain it yeah you
look good man especially i mean coming
off that big victory this must have been
a uh
satisfying one i'm sure um
you're aware of all the things going
into this fight so a lot of people are
rooting for you they didn't do homeboy
any favors pairing them up with you
you've been on this freaking
banshee of a freaking
streak just destroying dude since you
got in the ufc from the contender series
uh did you feel pressure going into this
one
no i i didn't feel any pressure honestly
like i i just tried to put everything
else just kind of like
uh you know it's all just noise to me
you know i i don't need
i don't need to put any added pressure
on myself you know because i already put
a lot of pressure on myself to try to do
what i can to be perfect you know even
though that being perfect is like
something that's
never going to be able to attain
something just being perfect you know
so
for me i already put a lot of pressure
on myself so i'm not putting letting
anybody else or anything put any more
pressure on me so you know yeah you know
he he kind of he [ __ ] that he [ __ ]
it he [ __ ] himself up for that
uh just saying what he said but you know
just gave me a whole bunch of fans on
that end so uh you know he got mad at me
during that whole uh during the whole
thing like people had kept asking me
about about all that stuff you know so i
was just like oh you know
it is what it is but [ __ ] i got to knock
him out yeah he did get to knock him out
which i think was satisfying for a lot
of fans out there and definitely earned
you more fans did you take his comments
i didn't take it as bad as most the
media did obviously the media runs with
that stuff
you know i i thought it was distasteful
but i was like oh this is terrible he's
a kkk member you know i was like yeah
the guy's in the middle of a fight
there's i poke said dirty brazilian it
is what it is
oh yeah
honestly i i honestly always look for it
to try to sympathize with people because
i'm just like you know i looked at what
he said and i was like it's not the best
thing he can say
dude i corner fighters all the time like
i corner my training partners all the
time so uh i'm i'm i've never had to go
back to be like look like look at that
like brazilian i never had to do that
i'll always go look across the cage and
go you see that [ __ ] over there
you go after him you know that's that's
you know nothing against like not never
going after race but i kind of turned my
head sideways a little bit but that's
about it man i'm just like well he's
there cornering his significant other i
was like of course he's going to be in a
state where he's just not not there and
correct you know the media kind of all
like i gave him i cut him slack and i
never said anything like talking [ __ ]
towards him i was like i get it because
he's there cornering his significant
other like man i don't want to see my
girl get punched in the face hell no man
that completely sucks that's going to
put me in a different like of course my
heart would be racing my thumping
emotions and all that [ __ ] so
yeah so yeah and i i cut him some slack
it's just a a lot of mma media uh i'll
be like yeah i know a whole bunch of
brazilian fans just definitely want to
see me knock him out for bigotry and
they'll click bait that and be like oh
yanez said brazilian fans want to knock
him out for big he's going to not knock
him out for for bigotry and all that
stuff's like no if you actually go into
the interview and actually
listen to it or read it you'll actually
find out that's not what i said you know
like the clickbait stuff in the back
even at the weigh-ins and then
behind the scenes at the wins he was
talking [ __ ] so i got screenshots like
bro you got clickbait headshots that's
not you didn't you didn't listen to it
you think you would know you know the
way the media is treated like come on
man they're trying to build this fight
and create a neither that's not there of
course they're gonna run with it now
you've had what five fights in the ufc
five bonuses what are we doing with all
this money in my mind what are we doing
all this money
trying to put it away i already got an
irs
ira set up for me and i'm actually
trying looking to start grabbing uh more
properties i just bought my first house
uh last year so
i'm getting i'm finally dipping my toes
into all this stuff because man growing
up i never i never really kind of had
anybody tell me what i should be doing
with my money yeah and now that i'm here
like i had to pay taxes these past
this past year and i'm looking at how
much i had to pay and i was like whoa
what the [ __ ]
you live in texas right i live in texas
so i got blessed with not having like
this is a big reason why i'm like i'm
not fighting in new york not finding
california i'm cool i'm cool with
fighting in texas and nevada that's it
i'm cool with those two places because i
don't want to be paying anybody else's
taxes
i cry every tax season i cry living in
california my man they'll take half your
money it's a beast but you get what you
pay for um
did you have a good father's day because
you are a dad you have a younger son
yeah yeah
yeah man my son uh so two like a week
and a half ago he turned six months and
yeah he showed up to the fight so right
after man it was it was the most amazing
thing in the world like uh they took
pictures of him like ah so oh man i i'm
telling you holy [ __ ] hold on it was it
was a whole experience for me because
like uh walking out at the weigh-ins
they showed up like legitimately they
drove from uh houston
to austin in a couple hours uh we they
get there and they're texting me where
they're at and i'm just as soon as i'm
walking i'm looking for them in the
stands i see i see my girl she's holding
him up and i'm just like i started
having my moment you know i was like
dude this is like this is the best thing
in the world i'm seeing my son over
there in the crowd and i'm like going
nuts and then uh
after the fight like uh after i finished
after i finished tony kelly like the
first thing that was on my mind i just
couldn't stop yelling and i was like uh
do you see caught it a little bit with
where i was just yelling like where's my
boy like i'm trying to look in the fans
trying to look all around i just wanted
to go hold my son and then after
uh
man as soon as i saw as soon as i saw my
baby i was just like ah dude i just i
just i i didn't want to let him go man
better go nothing better brother oh and
he said he's six months he's six months
you said
yes six months old so he's still not
really aware what's going on and how
much of a badass his dad is but as he
gets older you know he'll start picking
up on things you know oh yeah a little
bit man i'm hoping so man but i try i i
i keep it very loving around him like
but it's it's weird because like it's a
uh
i don't know i don't know if what it is
but like
he's not attractive like he watches all
this other like he'll have like cartoons
on it he's like what cartoons will be on
on tv or something not really paying
attention to it but a fight pops up and
he's like looking i'm like yeah man i
was like i think uh and
there was one time i think it was a i
was re-watching peter peter young versus
corey shanahan and he just sat there and
watched the whole fight with me and i'm
like oh [ __ ] like he was like that was
weird i'm like bro like do you even
understand i'm just holding them like
like are you kidding me like you're just
watching a fight right now
i don't want him i don't want him to
fight oh man
better trust me man yeah but you know i
tell my kids that there's no ufc
fighters come out of calabasas
california buddy you know i tell them
all the time he loves jiu jitsu i got to
take him later today jiu jitsu and i you
know i like him to have the discipline
and you know
try and pursue something but it's like
this isn't your path dude like i got
punched in the face so you don't have to
my man
oh man that's that's that's exactly
that's exactly what i'm trying to do
right now i'm trying trying to
uh get punched his face as least
as i can so whenever he's growing up and
everything i can be coherent yes and
like actually like have my moments with
him because i i loved that moment that i
had with him you know and then even just
in general just watching the small
little things that he does like man he
just started having uh some actual like
food and just watching him have the
actual food and just like transitioning
a little bit so i was like
those moments man were amazing to me and
then coming home they gave me uh they
gave me my father's day present and it
was like
i never thought i'd be emotional over
something small like that but they had a
customized book for just me and my son
oh no and with like figures that looked
like yeah and i'm like
i was expecting like socks or underwear
or something like that you know
yeah yeah and then they gave me a book
uh my girl got me a book customized for
me and him and that brought me to tears
man i was just like so those moments
like i i want to have those moments a
lot more with my son going to this first
like going to his first uh school going
going taking them to pre-k kindergarten
and i i just want to be coherent and
then when he graduates i don't want to
be the uh
i don't want to be having the the little
shake syndrome and i want i want to be
coherent whenever i'm with him yeah you
don't want to be drooling at his
graduation i think the good thing is is
you know you don't really get hit you
know what i'm saying like you're you're
elusive your footwork you know the way
you maneuver you're not really getting
hit you know you're off to this insane
start in the ufc i don't know if you saw
the clip that you see put up leaning
into your fight but they were like you
know don't sleep you know because this
dude brings it so and they did a whole
montage of all your highlights and
you're like jesus christ dude so for you
it's like
you know you're you're off the 5-0 start
you got to start in the contender series
you have five bonuses five wins
i you know i tell guys this all the time
like you know sugar shawn was here
patty i'm like dude it's a marathon not
a sprint my man like
learn from me man like because i was
like oh i need to get a top shot as fast
as possible so give me the toughest guys
that you can the ufc all right my man if
that's what you want to do and i wish i
had someone who's been through it to go
whoa whoa dude it's a marathon buddy
like this is not a sprint get your
experience take your time you know get
to your third fourth contract where
you're making real money so for you i'm
sure you feel a little pressure because
the fight world you know no matter who
you are
you know when you're coming up
especially the way you're coming up
they're going to want this oh i want to
see adrian verse this guy you know this
top five guy the champion it's like whoa
dude take it easy yeah so do you feel
that pressure do you do you know i guess
because you'll see guys too like and you
know the ufc takes part in this as well
the pressure from fans that go what's
next call somebody out like what's next
and they want you to call somebody out
but you know
it's it's a tough line to kind of toe
there my man especially you having all
this hype right now yeah
oh yeah no 100 percent like i i 100 like
understand everything and why the fans
want to do that because it it just
brings a whole little spectacle about
everything man there's like people being
like man like like holy [ __ ] like how
sick would this fight be adrianas versus
peter young and i'm like that dude just
lost the titles like bro like there's no
there's no reason i'm like then uh you
know i did call out sugar shawn because
he called me out you know he used to
spend time calling me out yeah he's oh
he's been calling me out for for a while
like uh after my david grant fight he
was calling me out so okay uh but also
even even in his situation
like
like i we're on the phone call with the
ufc and we're both wanted to fight
but
i think the uc had different plans for
him and myself of course he's fighting
pedro munoz which even if he fights him
it like even if he fights him i was like
beat tim there's no reason why sean
o'malley is going to take a step back
and try to fight me he's still like a
step or two ahead of me anyway so i'm
like yeah there's no reason for him to
look back he still has like a couple
fights they can look going forward which
are perfect fights for them you know so
even people just don't even look at
they're like no no you see that you're
scared of when you're doing this you're
you're dodging all these fights like no
no it's like there's just a lot of [ __ ]
that just goes on that you can't really
can't control because there's no way i'm
going to be fighting like a peter yan or
rob font those guys right now i was like
brother there's still a building process
that needs to happen i can't
automatically fight these guys who are
in the top top five top eight because it
just doesn't make sense you have to
continue to build them honestly too as
well like i don't mind i don't mind
waiting another fight or two to even try
to even get a rank ranked number right
next to my name so uh again like i'm in
my second contract right now i'm halfway
through that halfway through that and
then you know again to that third third
contract and start seeing some better
numbers then yeah of course the top 15
started start looking at those guys 100
but
i definitely want to build that yeah
it's all business yes at the end of the
day these fans are these fans are super
fickle so they'll they'll cheer for you
one minute and then uh
and the next minute they're booing you
so i get it 100 so
yeah that is what it is it's all
business move with that stuff i think
too
you know when you start finding those
top 15 guys you want to be compensated
like a top 15 guy because
god will and hopefully you storm through
them like you've been doing but you
start finding some of these other guys
running the top 15 these vets like it's
it's gonna be a fight
there's a reason why they're there you
know so it's gonna be a [ __ ] fight
and you know if it's a fight you're
you're definitely risking like you
talked about those moments with your son
it's taking away from your family you
know there is you know unfortunate part
of the sport is that stuff will catch up
to you so it's like you need to be
compensated if you're fighting those
caliber of guys you know and i think the
narrative is changing guys like sugar
shawn patty you know even al joe right
now going hey i'm not gonna fight tj in
september unless i get a pay bump man
like i've earned that and you guys gotta
you know step up and and pay me more
which i like seeing that um but it but i
like seeing that the narrative's
changing a little bit where guys are
smart we're like i might find a top 10
guy you know i'm still on my first
contract so you guys are getting more
savvy to it which i appreciate
oh yeah 100 like i i look i i kind of
grew up and started telling myself
whenever i got into this and i got into
the ufc i told myself i was like i don't
want to be another 30 for 30. i'd be one
of those guys that like goes in there
and just like has a hell of a career by
the end of the day has nothing to speak
for you know i i definitely don't want
to be that guy that gets
they even gets money goes broke you know
i don't want to be that guy whatsoever
you can't be happy
it made me like actually especially even
having him it made me start thinking
about
everything else like not only just money
it started making me feel like i had to
start carrying myself differently i have
to do everything else differently
because i can't like i can't be having
these like i can't be
like not emotional but i can't act
emotionally whenever i'm making
decisions that to make sure i'm
level-headed and cool you know and i had
to make sure that he navigates his
emotions in a navigated and cool way you
know i can't let him
uh see whenever like just even just in
general this fight in the middle of that
fight uh he starts talking [ __ ] to me i
say cool calm and collected then
afterwards you know after the fight is
over then i get a little bit more
animated because like man
but also
uh
after afterwards you know uh i get to
start thinking about the finances a
little bit and started looking i was
like all right cool now i can set this
this aside for him i can start doing
this i can start doing that and makes
everything
my life a lot easier but now going into
a little bit further i want to start
making sure that i start building off of
this and start building like more money
start being able to uh
invest a lot more because man dude i'm
telling you i want to make sure my kids
set up for life 100 brother there's
nothing like a kid a sober yep real
quick stop being a dumbass and if it
doesn't you're just a bad person but um
i you know i i do think
you know too with social media like your
kids he's only six months he says a
couple years but let's say you go on
some crazy tangent about whatever man
you know it it falls down on your son
you know [ __ ] rolls downhill so your
son's gonna have to deal with that abuse
at school man you know what i'm saying
and by the time he's it with classmates
and stuff like that like you know you'll
be a huge name you know god willing
you'll be this huge name you keep doing
what you think so you know his dad's
this famous fighter so now the kid your
[ __ ] your son's gonna have to deal
with that backlash man [ __ ] man even
just like let's just make this super
extraordinary but look at the uh
president like the former president uh
trump man look i i would i would
wonder how that uh i get i think his
name is barron trump i wonder how even
he is handling all that stuff that makes
me think of like this is smaller but
this is like magnified 100 so i'm like
damn uh
that that got to be something but even
though he likes the crown heavy lies the
crowd
you know if your grandpa's freaking
donald trump whether you agree with them
or not that kid's getting abused no
matter what dude you know yeah
left left and right so like yeah you got
to put things into perspective and then
because this is even though it's a lot
smaller still means as much to me as
does to everybody else and to them you
know so i'm like i look at i look at uh
i look at my son like nah i like i gotta
make sure he has a good head on his
shoulders i gotta make sure he can
navigate through through this life as as
best as i can like guide him through it
you know and his best at you keep saying
it's small time right now but you know
i i believe you have all the the tools
and the assets and the star power to be
championed you know what i'm saying i
know you believe that so it's like what
you do now that's always going to be
come it's going to come back to haunt
you you know negative or positive
they're going to bring that stuff up so
right now it might be small time my man
but obviously your manager and everybody
around you in your circle and training
partners know what where this
destination's headed so you know you got
to move like that you know you got to
move like a champ even though you're
just getting started
oh yeah no i always always have that
like uh try to keep that
i do my best to make sure i don't get
wrapped up in all the
excessive stuff like i i like i like
being like i still have the same group
of friends that i've had since i was in
the very beginning like since the very
beginning because that's dope man like
i'm not i'm i don't like being around
people that's just going to kiss my ass
the whole entire time
and all that [ __ ] so uh
like i still have my my friends they'll
call me they'll be like hey like you
know you know you're just still kind of
a piece of [ __ ] right and i'm like yeah
i know i know man
yeah i know but
no uh but yeah i i do try to keep that
little bit of like a down-to-earth type
of stuff but no when it comes to
training it comes to fighting i i know
that there's like i have this drive to
keep on going and keep moving forward
keep doing more but i'm always going to
try to have that little bit of humility
to make sure that i'm like i'm down to
earth man like i try i
i don't want to forget how how much work
it took to get there because correct man
it took a lot of work yeah i think
you'll be all right my man i saw on uh
on your instagram a while ago you posted
your training with al jermain sterling
you flew up there to train with al joe
yeah i trained i trained with them uh
back before he had the ufc had pulled
him out of uh that
whenever they were gonna rematch the
first time yeah i went up there
yeah legitimately like they pulled him
out and i was flying out the next day
and i was like oh i was like i was
calling and i was like hey bro like
we're still good to go like
like what was going on he was like nah i
was like oh it's like i've been good
it's like they just pulled me out
because
whatever whatever they had going on yep
uh you know he pulled out they they
pulled him out and you know i got to
train with them and then i trained to
train with them this
this year
uh right at the beginning of march and
and i
i knew right after right after those
training sessions i was uh that i felt
that he was going to get the win over
beer oh really did you
when training with al joe did it kind of
solidify what you you know the belief in
yourself from being champ because you
see the way al joe works who's an
incredible fighter i'll just he's a
champ for a reason you know so when
you're around that caliber of fighter uh
did you did you learn things from them
did it validate kind of your belief in
yourself what was your takeaway or
sometimes you go up there you know i've
been in situations where i go train with
these big names and you're like i got
work to do man like i'm a far cry away
from the champ right now
yeah man uh it was one of those things
that like it validated that i'm on the
right path but also it was like it did
both for me it was like i need to work
on this
and i'm on the right path because i'm
i'm i'm steadily working i'm not getting
lazy i'm not doing this because like i'm
like i'm i'm good right now and then
even just with them like even just with
algebra just in general like he was
helping me out like just giving me a
whole bunch of like hey
you know like invest your money don't be
stupid like he was actually like giving
me like life advice too as well so he's
a really cool guy all solid dude all all
around so
uh to me it did it it did wonders every
single time i went up there so i i'm
forever i'm gonna be forever grateful to
al joe for helping me out and then also
kind of like being the guy's like no you
can do this like he even like was like
no you can do it like you you're to be
you're going to be one of those guys one
of the days and he's like gosh that that
made me feel so much better because man
like i i'm always like kind of again
like it goes back to me always kind of
just i don't think i'm that good but
then after a while like i'm like oh okay
i am that good so yeah
yep yeah like i am that good you know
but it it sometimes it's still hard for
me to because i'm just like man i'm from
like laporte like i'm from this like a
suburb from houston i'm like man i ain't
[ __ ] i'm nobody so but at the same time
like whenever i go against these guys
and like i i just know i'm like oh okay
i am that guy yeah i love it man as far
as what's next for you anything on your
radar is anybody you want to fight what
are you thinking dude
man honestly this is kind of a weird
spot because the two guys that that
that had called me out well like i like
i got a hit list like three people
called me out uh tony kelly was one of
them knocked him off the list uh nate
manus he's
he he was one of those guys but also he
has a tough fight and he has a tough
fighter uh fight in front of him and
i'm not sure if he gets that
i'm not sure if he gets that victory if
i'm being honest you then uh sean
o'malley but also sean o'malley if he
beats pedro again that kind of he's like
he ain't looking back he's he's on he's
on the way forward so uh it's just all
up in the air for me right now uh but i
do want to try to get back in october if
possible
sophia is kind of yeah just wait and see
the ufc and obviously the ufc is a fan
of you because you know
and i said this before he came on i said
i think this now you open up the main
card on that fight night i think
moving forward you know you're gonna be
higher on those fight night main cards
but i think they'll start having the
open pay-per-views i think that's what's
next for you oh yeah man i don't mind i
don't mind opening up main cars because
that's where the most eyes get like they
get the most guys on the main card
uh
the
the featured about on the prelims is
cool too but i'd rather just be opening
up the main card uh come in come in come
in at times for fight nights and two uh
main event of fight night i think that
would be an amazing experience so
especially so i can start getting five
rounds in uh start getting that main
event exposure on fight nights so it
just builds me up even higher and then
after that you know i think the pay
reviews would be amazing too because
those are a whole bunch of eyes as well
so
any little any spot that i can get that
has a lot of eyes that's exactly where i
want to be at yeah i like you kicking
off the main cards on a pay-per-view
because it sets the tone and your
fight's never boring so it's like you
know how it is when you're back in those
locker rooms like if you go out there
you do your thing it kind of it makes
everyone it brings the best out of
everyone like oh damn this dude's you
know showing out so everybody else yeah
you gotta step their game up so i i
think right now you're perfect for that
man i hope and i think the ufc obviously
sees it
oh yeah it that honestly i i really hope
they do too uh i saw in the back because
i saw uh dana white and joe rogan jump
out their seat after this one so i was
pretty excited about that like i didn't
notice in the moment where they were
sitting at
uh but yeah like after watching the re
replay and i saw them jump up and just
be like holy [ __ ] i was like that's so
[ __ ] cool but yeah that's the first
fight rogan came to and wasn't working
in a hot second probably i don't know 10
years at least
yeah and you know what and actually to
be the main the main card opener for
that that that to me was also like a
pretty cool man because i like again man
i'm a big fan of like the big fan of the
joe rogan and georgia experience and i'm
i'm like i do i used to work a
nine-to-five job just trying to work and
try to get to the ufc and everything so
joe rogan experience and not to not to
kiss ass or anything like that but i
listen to you and brian i love my
younger kid i love it and i listen to
two bears one cave man
dude i'm
no i'm all the way in so oh yeah
i'm 100 so i've been i've been a big fan
also too not again
back in the day uh when mark munoz used
to have his uh used to have rain
training center uh
i was there for about a month oh really
yeah yeah i was training with uh eric
eric perez and uh dance bermudez and all
those guys they're great yeah yeah y'all
y'all uh y'all heavyweights are training
there and i just remember just looking
at like god damn they y'all
[ __ ] are big big boys yeah
those are good times man
yeah i remember seeing the
remember seeing you in the gym i saw
michael bisping in the gym i saw ryan
hall and lorenz larkins bar and to me
that sparring session like i just i
remember sitting back and watching them
spar
and i wish
that fight would actually i don't think
fans would truly appreciate how
how good those two guys are because that
was the most technical sparring session
i have ever seen nuts uh like it was
just absolutely nuts and it was just
yeah i wish i wish
like
that [ __ ] that you not even man they
could put the the 16s and chain guards
on
pay to watch that yeah i would have paid
to watch that let's get some of those
training sessions out man you could you
could air those and charge people 299
and make a real business out of it if
you wanted to um yeah that's crazy i
didn't know you went to rain that's
[ __ ] great dude um
what else is interesting you also do uh
you've done a tough mudder you did the
dallas tough mudder
yeah yeah
so i'm doing a tough mudder in dallas in
october i'm gonna do the one i think
it's on october 30th 29th the 30th but i
did uh the one in college station we
were trying to do the 15k one but they
didn't offer it at that time
i guess just the course wasn't like big
enough for the place that they had it
just wasn't big enough so we did the 10k
uh it was honestly we were super excited
man i loved it man that's so fun it's so
so fun yeah i'm obsessed
i do another one
because yeah contractual i have to do
four year with them i i think my next
one is in chicago
end of august if you don't have a fight
man you everyone come up come run with
me man i'll take care man yeah oh man
100 i would love to go to one i'm
telling you i
after that experience and just after
doing the the ten
i was just like once once we got over
mount everest and we started doing the
uh once we started walking towards the
electro therapy remember seeing it and
being like man this is it like i need 15
i got like i started feeling like no i i
wanted to be like i want to start going
for that 12 hour i was like
i started going like david goggins in my
own head like steve [ __ ]
it's so yeah it's just such a fun
experience something to do with your
boys it's like a bonding thing like you
know we have there's the tough mudder
and then we have our division the thick
mudder so it's me and like all my boys
fans and it's just it's just it's just a
fun experience something to do and like
halfway through when i can tell people
are tired and they're like man i wish
the insider was 15k we're like on top of
a mountain i'm like what else would you
be doing on a saturday like how dope is
this we're all covered in mud we're wet
like we're all together yeah
yeah no there was there was one moment
where i see uh my friend uh my friend
lupe he's also a really big fan he
actually has thick boy merch and
everything
big fan big fan love it uh we were sit
we were sitting on top right right in
front of the cold plunge and he just was
just like oh [ __ ] i was like come on bro
we got this and like yeah that [ __ ] was
just it was fun because after going
through it he's going through it he's
just like oh [ __ ] i'm happy i feel like
i'm happy i did that i was like
i could tell he was just there he was
just like i was like man yeah no you got
it bro you got it yeah i i just love
doing them we're gonna have to do one
together man that'd be fun you know oh
yeah
especially not find october we can make
this happen man oh bro i i'm telling you
i i'm down i am down to go anywhere uh
honestly if if they have a 20k one i
would be down because that 10k felt a
little too easy for me yeah yeah i feel
you 15k towards the end you're kind of
like all right i'm good 15k is the
perfect amount 5k waste time 10k you
know it's cool but 15k is where it's at
man i like it okay all right
we'll do it man you got my word and chin
has your info right you have his info
you have his managers i'll text you when
we get off here once i lock it down
we'll figure it out man we'll fly fly
out there and we'll we'll do this thick
mudder together brother yeah it's like
august 27th it'll be fun though august
26th oh man hell yeah yeah depend when
your fight is but we'll figure it out
dude but uh man i've been a fan for a
while
you're taking the ufc by storm you got a
great head on your shoulders you're a
good dad and uh i'm just excited man
there's nothing better i tell the guys
all the time on the show or if we're in
studio whatever we're doing like there's
nothing better than the come up like
what you're doing right now like stop
and smell the [ __ ] roses my man
because it's so special and you're going
to get to the top and you can get up
there and the view is not going to be as
good as you thought it was and you can
get used to all this money and fame but
the come up right now is the best part
man so try to stop and smell the roses
if you can i know it's nice oh man yeah
then i don't know how much more time we
have but man like again like that
that what you just said is exactly what
i have been doing especially with just
everything in general like in my life
that's happened
uh
my coach like my coach has always told
me my dad has always told me that like
you know
be in the moment
be in the moment don't always look
forward don't always look forward
because you start missing what's in
front of you and my coaches my coach was
a was a big advocate of that because he
was like yeah tito ortiz had did that
rico rodriguez did that the guys who had
who had we had trained before like they
they did that and they kind of got you
used to is like and he's like
just take pictures remember always just
remember where you're at when i first
flew out to the contender series you
just he was like just enjoy this moment
we're riding in the limousine and i'd
like at that time the only time i've
ever been in a limousine is whenever i
was writing for quinceanera and all that
stuff so yeah man
for me like i was just like man this is
amazing i'm getting flown out by the ufc
and
everything like just all those moments
flying out to fight flying back flying
to and like and just enjoying all those
moments seeing new things uh man that
was like the first time i other than
california i've been to a new state so
like just
traveling and all that stuff so i i'm
enjoying every bit of it man and i and
and i'll and honestly like with uh
my coach not being here i now like
really make sure i enjoy these moments
man because i was in that cage and i was
just like man like on uh this past
saturday
i remember looking up and seeing my name
like in the lights looking at the crowd
and just kind of feel
apart like a part of me i i didn't let
it it it it was hurting me at that
moment but i tried not to show it
because i had to be like a killer in
that moment for sure but like i was like
my coach and my dad were always in my
corner and like the fact that they both
weren't there at the biggest moment of
my career yep uh and like where they
told me i would be at one day and
you're there i get then i'm there you
know it and your son's there
yeah yeah you know and yeah so like i
yeah uh after after everything's kind of
said and done you know i i
i'm happy i took i took that moment in
instead of letting it overcome me and i
was just i'm forever grateful man i'm
forever grateful for the moments that i
have my coach forever uh
the moments that i have with my dad and
everything you know now it's my now it's
time for me to have my moments with my
son you know and make sure that he never
forgets that he never forgets any of
those moments you know yeah take it from
a guy who doesn't stop and smell the
roses my man it's just if you do that
it's just like a never-ending hustle and
you're not appreciating your hard work
but you got to figure it out man you
know we haven't talked i was like man
some guys come out they're super cocky
or whatever but i think you're going to
be all right dude um man it's just i'm a
huge fan over here i do that from the
get-go and uh we'll figure out this
tough mudder i'll text you when we get
done with this but i i can't tell you
how exciting it is to watch your come up
man and i can't wait to see what's next
hopefully it's not in august because
then we can't do the tough mudder but oh
yeah
brother yeah man yeah i appreciate you
brother i really do man now thank you so
much go take care of that little boy man
oh man i'm actually after in an hour i'm
actually this is the first time i'm
probably gonna get to do it uh but i'm
actually gonna go pick him up from
daycare because i'm this whole training
camp
all i all i got to do is drop him off in
the morning and that's the only time i
got to see him when i come home from
training he's asleep man so man i'm
about to me i'm about to have those
moments with my son man thank you so
much
yeah we love you here man and i'll be in
touch brother keep kicking ass dude
thank you all right brother take care uh
let's jump in the current bench dude
cool
uh let's see here that's the one you're
talking about so phil has i guess after
the fight he just sort of like chirped
at dc like you know you picked the wrong
guy or something like that i'll play the
video for you yeah please do hopefully
it doesn't do anything to us though
and the audio sucks here too that's okay
[Music]
he's jacked
up
next week
look at what happened why would i want
this fight right here
on the outside
you can do it better than that don't do
that
[Music]
yeah here's what's interesting is these
guys like there there's fighters who
will call out dc
and keep
poking the bear
y'all must have forgot how [ __ ] good
dc is at fighting inside that octagon
there hasn't been one guy who has
criticized him besides jon jones there's
not one guy who has criticized him who
won't get absolutely annihilated
right even thick dc right now would
absolutely destroy
anybody give him criticism whether it's
on commentating whatever it is
i don't know and he's a nice guy so like
me people talk [ __ ] to me and you're you
know we don't do much we're friendly
guys but i'm telling you dude push comes
to shove dc will snap your neck on live
tv you know what i'm saying yeah i don't
get it all this criticism they keep
giving it's like oh you must have forgot
he's one of the best to ever do it
all these guys criticize him haven't
even
touched the level of success dc has had
you know about first ballot hall of
famer i mean he's in the hall of it
first i mean dude tip of the spare one
the best ever do it light heavyweight
heavyweight won a heavyweight [ __ ]
one of the best heavyweight tournaments
of all time in strikeforce when was a
late notice replacement
you all must have forgot
but and also with haws here it's like
obviously dc has a relationship with the
other fighter so when he says oh you you
picked the wrong guy it's like
i just know him i don't know you
wouldn't even pick them yeah yeah i know
him we have a relationship but
i didn't pick him in this fight what do
you want me to do and dc wasn't biased
either i didn't have an issue no he
wasn't but i think what was cool with
mary haas again after a big win he's
emotional he knows dc is close with him
so he said you picked the wrong guy and
then again
dude dc is a fighter's fighter i mean dc
is a [ __ ]
fighter through and through man will the
best ever do it so if you start coming
at him you you know he's gonna defend
himself man
well haas did apologize and he said like
please he she said like please don't
fight me dc he knows he get
every everybody yes i don't care unless
jon jones starts mouthing off inside
octo and dc has to go in there and do
the post fight interview it doesn't
matter
anybody's gonna deal with so be careful
fellas you you're messing with the wrong
guy he's friendly he's chubby he looks
short i get it he's in a suit he looks
you take that suit off it's freaking one
of the best ever do it that boy's a
problem
um but i think ha is just emotional
essel didn't say anything too
disrespectful no but like dc he was like
yo whoa be respectful man this is my
work dude what are you doing he said you
didn't fight me trust me he didn't fight
me yeah i loved it i would have went
like this that was the dope part yeah i
love that you didn't fight me yeah
homeboy he didn't beat me no he didn't
beat me he even said like you think i
don't i didn't want him to fight you
like he this is the reason why he didn't
want him yeah he didn't want like this
matchup i didn't pick the fight
and then he was like yeah i apologize i
think he's just emotional he knows dc is
associated with him that's what all it
is yeah i it also wasn't that
disrespectful i like that dc drew a lie
in the same like you didn't beat me dude
i didn't pick this fight what are you
talking about he's like and i didn't
want this fight
but dc his his if i'm
his friend uh the guy who fought what's
his name the small guy oh the wrong one
yeah if i'm win
and i'm you know i'm dc i'm telling like
you gotta cut weight this ain't working
but dude he looks so awkward in there
he's too tiny it's not his arms his
wrestling's not he got taken down
yeah a nightmare it's not gonna work out
uh you mentioned eddie weiland being
overmatched and so after this fight he
did retire
it's my thing though eddie weiland
former world champion wc
he actually fought on the car i think he
fought you out of favor when i fought
crow cop in new jersey
um eddie weiland for the amount of
sacrifice and time he's given the ufc
there is with his boy shot daddy william
one of the greatsman and that mustache
is just fantastic i know fantastic and
still you don't see a lot of that
anymore but
for a guy like eddie wineland to
the the sacrifices he's made inside that
gun for them not to give him air time to
retire got a problem with it and you i
saw him take the gloves off yeah like he
was holding the gloves listen if you see
a guy take gloves off that fast and you
know he's at the tail end of his career
you got to give him the proper respect
and let him
sign off on air man like he had to post
about it yeah it's terrible that's not
the way you treat a guy yeah i wonder if
i could tell i was like oh i wonder if
they're going to give him his time like
oh wow you just walked you tell he's
like all right see ya yeah you know
production works sometimes it probably
like gets but it sucks either way cody's
statement's gonna go on and do great
things and fight for the next you know
six years probably mm-hmm
eddie weiland you know and you could say
you could have went to eddie william
first done that and like cody who's who
you want next that's it yeah yeah
come on man it was a mismatch this isn't
a good fight for eddie wylin you know
what you guys were doing
um we already covered joel's on love
eddie weiland though great such a nice
guy and again for you newcomers the ufc
go back and watch me [ __ ] wc he had
some phenomenal fun knockout dude yes
all right we knew this was coming but uh
yeah algerian sterling versus tj
dillashaw is going to be for ufc 279
september right that's what they're
saying yeah
but aldrin said i ain't deciding
anything exactly until they give me a
pay increase
good time to do it you know i think you
know he talks about being a company man
he's like you know i've played my role
of you know the the heel and i've made
you know made them money so so you know
so uh one would think that being a
company man will actually help you in
the long run so i did my job as right
now i'm training hoping that we come to
some type of agreement to give some type
of pay bump which naturally happens in
all contracts yeah so for those of you
who don't know usually the contract so
you find a six fight deal unless you're
i think bisping had something in vtor
jds where you get this huge flat fee of
like 400k or 500k and then it stays that
and then you get bonuses if you win
but you know you're talking about two
legends for al germain who still has
work to do right
you usually it goes like my contract was
like 16 and 16. 24 and 24 32 and 32
you know whatever 38 and 38 44 and 44 60
and 60. it always bumps up and he's
saying all right now i'm champ it just
stays the same that doesn't seem right
you know and then you're not getting
pay-per-view points until you do i think
you defend the bet like two or three
times it's weird the way they do it
there's no like actual
strategic uh
clear way on how they give those
pay-per-view points with champions so
i get it
i get it um i just don't know if the ufc
is going to budge you know
but
to al jermaine's uh defense i think now
is the best time to do it
i think he was waiting i was like yeah
yeah announce the fight
it ain't happening to give me a pay
increase
they could do it clearly they can't
afford it also with the ufc and i don't
know how much of a pay increase he's
looking for if it's like you know a
million bucks it ain't happening but if
he's just like i need some sort of
incentive where it bumps up uh
so this fiesta is taking a stance the
funk master revealed that he was paid
400
grand for his tile defense against young
which typically would include his share
of pay-per-view buys however according
sterling he hasn't seen the increase in
pay that's looking for his next fight
yeah you defend belt a few times before
you get pay-per-view points
400 sounds like a pretty decent amount
but for champ yeah well i mean he's
well i guess he's considered champ twice
now right yeah yeah
know not great
yeah
but to me interesting how it plays out
uh because when he says uh a bump i wish
you would have said how much of a bump
he's looking for because that's where it
gets a little dicey i'm with him you
should absolutely get paid wait
everybody should be paid more
sterling being the champ definitely has
more leverage because the division can't
move on they're not going to strip him
over this unless you know he holds out
for like a year or six months but
i would like to know maybe we should
call him up
we should come up definitely i'd like to
know how much he's asking for i don't
need the exact numbers but if he's like
i need a 10 increase or but if if he's
like i need double my pay if he's like
dude we ain't making that money off of
you you know
because he definitely deserves more now
is a good time to do it i'm just
wondering like how far are you willing
to take this algerman because again the
ufc unfortunately for the fighters the
ufc doesn't need anybody so in that
division they go cool we'll toss this
game
we're going to strip your belt make this
and turn belt you know yeah they've done
it before oh yeah plenty of times i hope
he gets paid though he deserves it for
sure and he's right he's put on some
great performances he's champ pay the
man again pay the man depend what he
wants let's be realistic alderman
hold up this is not loading remember so
who does asking for like a certain
amount he was like they just don't pay
me enough
and he was asking for you know millions
of millions of dollars in this he's like
no we don't get enough
pay-per-view buys to bring him back like
that i know he's he's incredible but so
good just one of the best ever again one
of the best to ever do it
all right your boy corey san hagen
fighting song yodong september 17th for
a fight night meet event they're setting
my boy corey up corey sandhagen
one of aurora's finest might be the most
talented guy come out of aurora and if
you think about aurora fighters talk
about neymar cart dwayne ludwig
christian allen
um
you know monsters monsters monsters
monsters of course
cory sanjay you might have the best um
talent out of all those guys i just
mentioned including myself shane carwin
you know some monsters uh aurora
it's something in the tap water
turns into teenage mutant ninja turtles
um
i i just hate that they give him some
young dung i just i don't like it you
know sung young dung he's not ranked
right so
it's a a high risk for him no matter
what but
i don't think he's ranked as of now oh
they got him at nine now okay he's nine
nine verse four
you know and the division's pretty tied
up i get it
um i just four or nine again especially
in this division
ratings or rankings don't matter too
much
it's just you know corey sanhedrin
coming off that last fight
song young dung again he there's these
there's these boogeyman's the division
the sun young dung
this isn't a fight for cory to highlight
his skills
to me i when this got announced what oh
oh they're trying to pull one over on my
boy then what they're trying to do is
build up song young dung
and because and i've told this like
the ufc marketing internationals where
they're going to make their money now
this is from china he's from china
he's from china he's a young kid from
china looks good marketable
killer gets finishes
undefeated kid is a mother trucking
problem
for corey sango well let's see how good
he is i just don't like it
i just i feel like cory should be you
know fighting some other big names and
this kid is the next you know
he's like he's basically chung lei from
blood bloodsport he's trung late dude
he's a small chung li it's a [ __ ]
problem i hate it for my guy cory
and again super biased can corey win
this fight 100
i just don't like it as a career move i
don't like it another loss i don't like
it
i'd rather lose to like a dominic cruz
or you know something like that or
marlon vera you know cheeto or something
like that but
obviously cheetah and uh crews are
doing their thing but i just
you know
he's a big problem big problem yeah
that's a that's a tough season let's go
and take this over into china because
they're like if you if they start moving
to china which is a huge market for them
you think about it waylai they have
waylai right who's huge but you know
uh they don't have any uh male fighters
who are ki you know he's he's their
yeah he's their guy yeah i don't like it
i don't like it it's a very tough fight
for court very tough fight
um all right so greg hardy has signed i
think it's a multifide deal with pkfc
i like this way more than him trying
professional boxing
i think bkfc especially at heavyweight i
think uh for ed hardy he's a big name i
i'll definitely watch it i gotta be
honest what bkfc has been doing lately i
take him yeah it's entertaining dude
it's entertaining they're getting
quality fighters greg hardy people to
even the ufc even you
mismatched not a great fight pranic and
when we'd always tune in to greg hardy
you know
and again greg carty obviously his past
is dark dark dark and i get all that
but there is something to redemption
there's something of people learning
from the mistakes he was younger i don't
know exactly what happened yeah but
that's another thing yeah we don't know
um you know obviously the witness
i don't know if he's settled i don't
know what happened there i don't know
what happened there
what i do know is people that are his
coaches and training partners and they
go shop i'm telling you dude he is a
great guy yeah right he's respectful
he's a good trading partner he shows up
for everybody he just wants to learn you
know but
unfortunately when you have that baggage
it's you know it comes with territory
like people are always gonna find a
reason to try and bring you down for
whatever reason
you know that's a good reason with
domestic violence stuff but
i get it i get it but again all i've
heard from like legit good-hearted
people i'm telling you man maybe he made
his mistakes in the past since he's
walked into the gym been nothing but a
pleasure to work with good person
right now i don't know back in the i
can't judge him back there i don't know
him i don't know him now but i do know
the people that work with him tell me
he's a good guy yeah all right
it says right here um initially found
guilty but then the charges were later
expunged that means gone entirely from
the record because the victim failed
yeah so there's a lot more that we don't
we have no idea what happened next year
i saw the pictures too i think i showed
you before it was like the pictures
didn't look i'm not one to judge again i
don't know what happened i learned i
don't know yeah i wish i did
i also wish i knew what happened to oj
okay
prove it
okay court of law found a medicine right
civil court found guilty it's a tough
one but prove it did his son do it i'd
like to know him with jfk okay like no
having jimmy hoffa
i know more about what happened with jfk
than i do greg hardy or hoffa or o.j
simpson the jfk when i am balls deep in
if you see that new dock i think it's on
showtime with oliver stone you can now
it's a deep dive you got to pay
attention you can have your cell phone
probably should watch in two-part series
it's about two hours long i'd break it
up it's so much knowledge but you're
gonna watch and go oh there's no way lee
harvey oswald did this there's no way
you watch him like oh all right this is
the most convinced thing i've ever seen
it's it's insane like his brain like all
that it's nuts the magic bullet they
traced all of it
watch it get back to me all right that's
all i'm going to say
but the point is i don't know [ __ ] about
greg situation
and now the champs alan belcher
yeah heavyweight so
that'd be a crazy ass fight too
belcher's doesn't look like he used to
he's just jack
city baby
uh so is i beat i've got more dates or
mark dude natty or not alan belcher
i think mark will easily be like uh he's
on this you should look it up he was a
phenomenal fighter yeah in the ufc so
talented remember he uh he went on the
ground with paul harris the guy that
kept freaking beat the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah exactly because you're people i
don't belch a high level blackmail
you know so he was like oh you're things
knee bars and leg locks watch this and
was like go to the ground and just beat
the [ __ ] up yeah paul harris is on a
tough route lately i don't know if
you've been paying attention i haven't
he's fighting russia and these russians
just don't give a [ __ ] they are
beating his ass wow
okay so zabeet magametripov we maybe
started going to some medical field or
whatever but he's officially retired now
so he officially retired while he was on
top of the ufc
uh and he says disruptions of fights and
then health problems all this didn't
allow me to perform fight earlier i have
to recover now but i don't feel the way
i used to thank everyone who has
supported me for such a long time i
didn't have to become a champion but i
think even without this i hope i was
able to please entertain you you sure
did my man i cease to be an active
athlete i seize to be an active athlete
but i do not leave the sport i have
something with whom to share my
knowledge so don't say goodbye friends
good for him left on top
yeah i mean
the shame that if you're a fan of the
beat the shame is what it could have
been yeah right like you're so talented
so exciting i told you again there's no
one i respect more in the space of
coaching than mark henry and mark henry
called me
[ __ ] years ago dm me
i said called he dm'd i was like job i
hear you talking about all these got
fighters he's like i'm telling you man
we've never seen a guy like this the
beat kid i'm telling him he he doesn't
lose a round he's like please don't talk
about the his sparring partners and
these rounds but
you can talk about
think about the guys martin mariah in
his prime
frankie edgar uh barboza did you talk
about in in their prime
the beat never lost around
sane
and look at like he retired undefeated
in the ufc
undefeated
so yeah it's a bummer because you want
to know you know what the potential
could have been and
you know that calvin kader fight if it
had been five rounds what it would look
like yeah you know
um
but
listen there's no shame being like i
just don't want to do this anymore i'm
good i found something else i want to do
you know i don't people get upset but
it's like god god bless
the beat found something to do a lot of
guys get done and they don't know what
to do because their identities are show
fight fighter fight or flight like that
all they don't know is fighting
and what a gift for the beat to be have
the option to go i'm gonna do this
you know yeah like i'm so i think my
blessings every day like i was in the
middle of my [ __ ] career i was like
oh i i can do this something i'd rather
do oh thank god instead of how's this
end i stick around and what
hopefully become a kickboxing coach of
the ufc gym like that's how this ends
this is terrible
but fighters are becoming a lot smarter
athletes in general going a lot smarter
going
all right maybe i am a basketball player
right now but it doesn't define me or
maybe i'm an nfl player right now or ufc
fighter right now but doesn't define me
like it's a if you think if your life is
a book
your professional career in athletics is
one chapter of that book man unless you
know there's the outliers there's the
tom brady's there's the randy coutures
or you know these guys who you know
dominic cruz is that
jon jones that fought forever but those
are the outliers in general it's me a
very small chapter in your life book man
people going through your life after you
passed away it's a short chapter man but
so many guys define themselves yeah you
know
but
athletes become so much smarter you know
even like uh shaq when shaq retired he
he has like i don't know how many
freaking businesses a gazillion i don't
know who's his managers but you know
shaq was selling condoms dude right now
he sells condoms
he owns uh that the pizza joint you know
he's so much [ __ ] a ton of stuff but
even before this is the thing and didn't
get publicized but even before him
magic johnson didn't become a damn near
billionaire because he's a good
basketball player magic johnson uh
invested into movie theaters and
starbucks
and put them up all over dude that's how
he became a [ __ ]
icon mogul you know
no one's like there's guys that forever
have made moves to get him in the right
position but i don't know why it's not
more highlighted
all right yuri prahashka shaved off his
uh his antenna
what no
what if he just loses all his power now
i know that was his secret weapon you're
talking about chapters of lies so he
says he needed another or and one
chapter
and start with new energy
new energy new wave
let's see it oh there's no video no i
don't think there's a video he still
looks sweet
that beard is fantastic yeah
oh yes
let the new air begin
that's like a was that saber tooth
[ __ ]
what is that i don't know
man that's intense necklace
the shirt says
relax
the net the chain says
savage yeah
like the is that is that hawaii is that
his hometown and what is this i think
it's his hometown yeah memory went back
and had a huge reception oh my god yes
insane superstar now
the the the clash of the the
designs there i know pineapple shorts
and the pineapple shrubs shirt the top
floral shirt and a giant them with the
giant
i mean i don't know what to claw that is
that a bear's claw that he killed or
something i don't know this beard's
fantastic yeah i wish at that [ __ ] same
but the whole the whole the
the very tommy bahama vibe for the champ
here it's very confusing because it says
i want to relax but then this whole
demeanor here says i'm ready to fight
yeah it's very confusing
but yeah let it begin it's gonna be fun
man see what's you know okay really fun
uh also over the weekend jeremy stevens
had to shave his beard and his head
to make weight oh wow you can't even
tell that's him huh he looks so well i
watched this live okay i get another
mismatch i watched this live and i was
like oh he looked so much better with
his beard
that's how i recognize him man this is
like
yeah it's trippy he was but he made
weight such a little spark plug yeah
yeah pfl is fun
yeah and they're getting good guys it's
just that like it's fun you know it's
like
have you watched that other football
league it's on right now it's in the off
season the nfl i think the rock behind
or whatever
the xfl
it might be xfl i forget what they call
it but it's like
i was watching it more importantly i was
watching the half and i was just like
doing it wrong that's football
just like these other leagues are
fighting it ain't ain't the ufc they
ain't the nfl
it's just
it's just not
space
states yeah and you know like they want
to be somewhere else they just didn't
make you know it's like no one's like oh
i'm gonna play in for the whatevers los
angeles juggernauts instead of the rams
never
kyla harrison is the only person in pfl
going i'd much rather be here than the
ufc she's the only one everyone else
like me even the belter
it's the elephant in the room we all
know
you know you all know there's nothing
wrong with it
yeah we know
but then there's there's guys you know
who fight in the pfl like uh homeboy who
won the brazil ultimate fighter he was
like i've made more than a year fighting
bfl i made my attacker in the ufc oh
yeah
antonio carl's jr shoe face yeah yeah
yeah antonio uh junior he's like i've
made more in a year fighting pfl i do in
the ufc it's like yeah
but if you're successful in the fc if
you like were undefeated
that like
the amount of money you make in
notoriety is insane
what did you get jen
let me see um this i thought was just
it's not going to happen but gilbert
burton said that if he fought jorge
mazzura he'll put in the contract that
there's no takedowns so jorge could just
uh strike with him it's a fun headline
but the uc don't worry i know that i
know
that's what gilbert said be a fun fight
i'm so curious what they're gonna do
with those guys
yeah
god damn kevin holland stops alleged
perfume thief yeah this dude needs to
just stop fighting you see him become
batman i know this is insane another one
why is he always around crime too
i don't know but he's always finding
himself in these situations and he's
always the hero this is insane i mean i
sound like
it says uh
this is 24 hours before his ufc fight
holland's manager uh oren said the 29
year old fighter on friday stopped it
would be perfume thief i mean perfume
let it go
i mean perfume
no you're wrong they're expensive
stealing stealing but you're gonna 24
hours before fight you're gonna risk
injury to stop this guy from stealing
you know dior perfume i bet it was
johnny depp's dior man there's stuff
stuff to get they're selling like crazy
so survival yeah
you mean savage johnny you're from
kentucky dude quit talking like that
uh holmes manager oren uh stopped a
would-be perfume thief and lost my
chances down on foot if it haunts fast
too man yeah uh holland told mma junkie
he gave chase after seeing another man
shout out about stolen im1 pursuit of
the ledge thief the manager was unaware
of whether the alleged thief was
apprehended hall and then returned
several bottles of perfume i mean just
this dude is full blown
i mean this is insane he's a super
superhero
why is he always around it though
it's in there's just too many i don't
know how this is possible but i remember
john jones one time a long time ago
chased down someone that was my site
that was my when he fought um
shogun shogun yeah he was in new york
because we we did the press tour at the
radio city music hall
and we were both there and then yeah
shortly after that the city apprehended
a guy but then it came out where people
like that didn't happen like that
but i don't know
again i wasn't there i don't know
i know holland and this isn't like oh
holland is doing his thing man yeah
it's a real life kick-ass
kick-ass three kevin holland how does
the hollywood not put him in as the next
one of the guys he said he wants to do
movies after this he has a personality
all day yep all day
um this is a quick one this is just
patty the baddie when he was younger
he's all shy or what oh yeah he was
super shy and like he didn't look
anything like he does now and then this
is just a montage of him like kicking
ass afterwards oh he's phenomenal yeah
oh look at this look at this comet he's
good but over hyped it's like okay oh
yeah whatever
dude what do you want him to do how much
money that kid makes
for being over hyped
all right so this is just peter yan and
henry cejudo going back and forth on
social media
so peter young put uh it's at peter
young ufc hey henry sue you talked a lot
when you were retired now it's time to
back it up don't mind the fight but i
definitely think he's gonna take it and
that yeah henry's only gonna fight for
the title he only fights for gold
his name's triple c for god's sakes he
said only if you had the gold i would
have loved to have buried you you should
go back to dagestan and learn more
wrestling because you got out wrestled
by division three all-american that
wouldn't be smart of you taking an
olympic champ after that loss
uh
i'm after gold ho
theirs
and then peter says the truth is you
retired the day i became number one
contender and unretired on the same day
i ceased to be the champion now you
ducked me again only to prove those
facts
he says and you lost to al jo lame twice
do you think the olympic champ two
division ufc is going to play with sorry
ass contenders
your fat ass bolt manager is going to
get your get you hurt uh he misspelled
you that's all right he does some of the
spellings here yeah i'll give torment
off if you subscribe to my technique of
the week you know i'm getting the title
shoot next
i don't know if he's out of purpose he's
just firing it off you know it's tough
yeah peter john's not touching that
fight yeah hitting soon as i can come
out and fight you know volkanovsky or
for
35-45
gold he's earned it
guy retired as a double [ __ ] champ
yeah he's gotta fight for gold for sure
um this is okay the last one current
events at least
so this is a
fight that happened in a small
organization and the guy got kicked in
the nuts and then i'll show what happens
after that
[Music]
slattery looking to connect with those
heavy shots throwing that uppercut well
sauerkoff landed a few nice shots he's a
little bit strange
right in the weiner some white on one oh
he gets one time he's got rushed in
don't touch his wiener man revenge don't
touch the man's wiener
boy that fired up let me see just let me
see the wiener kick again okay
i mean that boy rushed in because that
he he thought he was going to stop like
kicking the wiener there he's like come
on man what oh go
boom
wiener power daddy
that's that dick power
i think well here it doesn't matter but
i think in the ufc if there's an eye
poke or a dick kick
the duck point no matter what yeah
there's no warnings automatically
because it changes the outcome of the
fight the guy's compromise kick me in
the nuts dude
come on yeah
god how photoshopped is this uh whole
thing here i don't know
but so this is at 3 p.m pacific on
saturday ufc card not the best but oh
this the great fight there is nail
magnet and shove cut romano tough fine
for nilmax yeah they're not doing my
boys any favors at all
the dolphin uh vieira is fighting who i
always like to watch fight our boy brian
kelleher is fighting mario batista yeah
the fight's not going to blow your hair
back but there's definitely some good
fights on there and also there's
bellator oh on friday hold on here it is
gage armasasi
and johnny eblin which i don't really
know much about johnny edwin but
i think it's title fight all i know is
gay guy mousasi that big dick energy you
go ahead and kick him in that big dick
see what happens dude choke you
unconscious
gigger got that big old dick man
legend says i'm telling you and then
there's also energy
a bkfc i don't recognize oh you i
remember paul amino from i think world
series is fighting or something yup and
then uh oh that's this is where beck
rollins is back in the yes we love back
rollins here at the shop show and that's
on a friday as well back doing the
goddamn thing
yeah i really like what uh bkfc's doing
man yeah i really do they're if you
actually sit down and watch it's a lot
of it's straight up yeah entertaining
yep it is so entertaining
well that's it kids uh hopefully
you enjoyed the show hopefully enjoyed
adrian i'm a big fan of him
um stand up wise tour wise uh la is this
wednesday shopping friends
oh we have a beastie lineup we got adam
corolla we got trevor wallace jeff dye
my boy craig conan um and then we have a
very very special guest who
if you gotta get tickets to the show
he's a monster uh very famous very funny
guy you will see him as the special
guest that's this wednesday 8 p.m only i
think it starts at 7 45 actually trying
to bump it up earlier so it might be 7
45 start time either way
one show only 745 hollywood improv uh
shop and friends with some monsters and
then uh the trash panda summer tour
continues in fort wayne indiana never
been there but the guys who own these
clubs are my favorite owners in the
business they own uh the bricktown
comicon oklahoma city the ones who set
me up with the emerson theater uh they
own spokane um and tacoma i think so
these guys just do it right and they've
never steered me wrong so i've never
been to fort wayne indiana it is a beast
to get there there's one hotel in the
town and we're staying there and mark
will be there as well with the shirt off
if you want to touch his nipples
so that is fort wayne indiana the trash
panda tour continues this merch the new
trash panda tour thick boy merch can
only get in person that will be in fort
wayne indiana and san diego is the laugh
factor in the heart of san diego uh
california laugh factory san diego july
21st the 23rd i also have special guests
there that's gonna be a big show uh and
then baltimore maryland is august 4th
through the 6th just added appleton
wisconsin september 8th to the 10th
houston boston or september get your
tickets at thickboy.com
uh the father's day sale has ended we
have new
thick boy tie-dye merch drop in end of
june it is some of my favorite [ __ ] uh
it's fantastic so all that is coming
very soon kids um but hollywood improv
this wednesday i think i have uh
the laugh i have spots at the lab
factory this week too so you can find me
on there it's on their lineup um i'm
there on friday at 8 pm for sure and
then saturday i'm doing jam in the van
in la too so i'm all over when i'm not
on tour i'm doing spots around la so
come get some um but yeah uh hollywood
improv wednesday in fort wayne indiana
you're next on the big tour dates there
and that's it kids i love you guys
thanks for subscribing liking uh we have
the big week coming up with uh food
truck guest i'm going to tell you who i
like to keep it a surprise
but that's it all right love you guys be
nice to each other
enjoy your holiday and i will see you
around the way love you bye
you